Krylov quantum diagonalization atau disingkat KQD mengacu pada penyelesaian masalah nilai matriks
dengan memproyeksikan matriks ke dalam subspace yang disiapkan pada komputer kuantum yang konsisten dengan metode Krylov, sebuah
pendekatan yang kuat dari aljabar linear klasik. Sepanjang video ini kita akan menjelajahi kegunaan metode Krylov
dan bagaimana serta kapan mengimplementasikannya pada komputer kuantum.
Jadi apa itu metode Krylov? Misalkan kita punya matriks H yang berkaitan dengan upaya ilmiah atau bisnis dengan n baris dan n
kolom. Kita tertarik pada nilai eigen terendah e 0 dan vektor eigen yang sesuai psi 0. Mari kita definisikan
vektor awal v yang mungkin dimotivasi oleh struktur h atau mungkin sepenuhnya acak. Krylov subspace
orde r yang kita tulis k r dihasilkan dengan menerapkan h pada
vektor awal ini sebanyak r minus satu kali, menambahkan hasil setiap tindakan h berikutnya
ke set vektor yang merentang, artinya kr adalah ruang yang direntang oleh vektor v,
hv, h kuadrat dan seterusnya. Vektor-vektor ini umumnya tidak ortogonal.
Secara klasik, kita sering melakukan proses ortonormalisasi yang sangat mirip dengan prosedur Gram-Schmidt. Kamu mulai
dengan menormalisasi vektor awal V dan menyebut hasilnya V 0. Kemudian untuk vektor berikutnya HV, kamu kurangi
proyeksinya ke V 0 untuk membuat dua vektor tersebut ortogonal. Kemudian kamu normalisasi hasilnya. Kamu terus seperti ini,
menerapkan H lagi dan membuat hasilnya ortogonal terhadap semua vektor yang sebelumnya ditambahkan sampai kamu membangun R
vektor ortonormal yang diperlukan untuk merentang Krylov subspace berdimensi-R kamu.
Setelah kamu memiliki subspace ini, kamu proyeksikan matriks ke dalamnya dan diagonalisasikan matriks yang lebih kecil yang diproyeksikan. Ada
detail dan ekstensi, tapi itulah metode Krylov pada tingkat paling sederhana.
Untuk lebih memahami cara kerjanya, mari kita lihat contoh yang sederhana. Kalau H adalah matriks ini dan V dipilih menjadi
vektor ini, maka kita akan mulai dengan menormalisasi V. Untuk menghasilkan vektor kedua dalam Krylov subspace, kita menerapkan
sekali H pada vektor awal kita dan kemudian membuat hasil itu ortogonal terhadap V 0.
Sedikit aljabar menghasilkan ini untuk V1.
Ini tidak berguna untuk matriks sekecil itu dan biasanya tidak akan berhenti pada dimensi Krylov dua. Tapi kalau kita
memproyeksikan H ke Krylov space baru K2, kita akan melakukan ini menggunakan matriks V
yang memiliki vektor Krylov untuk setiap kolom dan transposi konjugatnya yang memiliki vektor Krylov untuk baris. Kita kemudian akan
mendapatkan matriks ini.
Matriks ini secara teknis memiliki dimensi yang lebih rendah dari matriks asli kita. Jelas, reduksi ini tidak berguna pada
skala ini. Metode ini dimaksudkan untuk mereduksi matriks dengan ribuan atau bahkan jutaan baris dan kolom menjadi
hanya beberapa. Jadi kenapa metode Krylov berguna? Ternyata resep sederhana
dari aksi operator ini seringkali merupakan cara yang paling efisien untuk mendekati state nilai terendah atau ground state dari
operator matriks. Mari kita buat ini sedikit lebih eksplisit meski kita menyerahkan bukti lengkapnya ke teks yang menyertai. Kita ingin
menyelesaikan masalah berbentuk h yang bekerja pada vektor x memberi kita suatu konstanta kali vektor x. Mari mulai dengan
tebakan vektor eigen kita x0. Ini hanyalah solusi aproksimasi. Ini memiliki kesalahan yang kita sebut e 0. Sekarang kita ingin
membuat pembaruan dari tebakan ini yang akan kita sebut x1 yang kita harap meningkatkan aproksimasi kita. Kita bisa mengekspresikan ini sebagai
x0 asli ditambah beberapa koreksi p 0 yang belum ditentukan. Kita bisa
mengulangi proses ini secara iteratif dengan menambahkan lebih banyak vektor koreksi pi.
Jelas kita ingin kesalahan kita berkurang tapi bukan hanya state yang kita perhatikan. Kita juga peduli dengan
aksi h pada state tersebut. Jadi kuantitas yang benar-benar ingin kita minimalkan adalah norma-h dari kesalahan ini atau norma dari
aksi h pada kesalahan ini.
Sekarang kita bisa melihat bahwa ini adalah ekspresi yang melibatkan p 0 dan kita bisa bertanya pada diri sendiri pilihan p mana yang meminimalkan
norma-h dari kesalahan ini paling efisien. Dari ruang mana kita harus memilih koreksi? Dalam kondisi
tertentu seperti ketika h simetris dan positif definit, memilih r koreksi pertama dari dalam kr ternyata
optimal. Dalam istilah yang lebih sederhana, kita butuh cara untuk menyiapkan subspace yang baik di mana kita bisa
memproyeksikan Hamiltonian kita. Dan dalam banyak kasus, Krylov subspace adalah ruang yang direntang oleh vektor-vektor dari koreksi
yang paling efisien untuk tebakan awal kita.
Untuk bukti nyata, lihat teks yang menyertai video ini.
Semua yang sudah kita jelaskan sejauh ini bisa dilakukan secara klasik. Jadi, bagaimana dan kapan kita akan menggunakan komputer kuantum?
Untuk matriks yang sangat besar, metode Krylov bisa membutuhkan waktu komputasi yang lama dan memori yang besar. Waktu
yang diperlukan untuk operasi matriks H pada V berskala seperti N kuadrat dalam kasus terburuk.
Dan ini dilakukan untuk setiap vektor yang kita inginkan dalam subspace kita. Dimensi subspace R biasanya bukan merupakan
fraksi yang signifikan dari N dan seringkali berskala seperti logaritma dari N. Jadi menghasilkan semua vektor berskala
seperti orde N kuadrat kali log N.
Meskipun ada langkah-langkah lain seperti ortonormalisasi, ini adalah skala dominan yang perlu diingat.
Quantum computing memungkinkan kita mengubah atribut masalah apa yang menentukan skala waktu dan sumber daya
yang diperlukan. Daripada bergantung pada ukuran matriks n secara keseluruhan, kita akan melihat hal-hal seperti jumlah shots dan
jumlah suku Pauli yang tidak komutasi yang membentuk Hamiltonian.
Mari kita jelajahi cara ini bekerja.
Ingat bahwa operator yang mengevolusi waktu state kuantum adalah eksponensial dari iH dibagi h bar. Dan ini sangat
umum, terutama dalam quantum computing, untuk menghapus h bar dari notasi.
Salah satu cara memahami dan bahkan merealisasikan fungsi eksponensial dari operator semacam itu adalah dengan melihat ekspansi deret
Fourier-nya. Perhatikan bahwa operasi ini yang bekerja pada beberapa vektor awal V menghasilkan jumlah suku
WEBVTT
dengan pangkat H yang semakin meningkat yang diterapkan pada state awal. Sepertinya kita bisa membuat Krylov subspace kita hanya dengan mengevolusi
waktu state tebakan awal kita. Dan itu hampir benar. Caveat-nya ada dalam
merealisasikan evolusi waktu pada komputer kuantum nyata. Banyak suku dalam Hamiltonian tidak akan komutasi dengan
satu sama lain. Jadi sementara beberapa operator eksponensial sederhana seperti e pangkat negatif i z sesuai dengan circuit yang sederhana,
Hamiltonian umum tidak demikian dan karena mengandung suku-suku yang tidak komutasi
kita tidak bisa begitu saja menguraikan eksponensial menjadi produk dari yang sederhana seperti yang bisa kita lakukan dengan angka. Jadi
ini tidak sepele tapi ini adalah proses yang sudah dipelajari dengan baik dalam quantum computing. Kita melakukan evolusi waktu
pada komputer kuantum menggunakan proses yang disebut trotterisasi yang itu sendiri merupakan subjek yang kaya. Tapi pada tingkat yang sangat tinggi
dengan memecah evolusi waktu menjadi langkah-langkah kecil katakanlah M langkah kita membatasi efek dari non-komutativitas
suku-suku tersebut. Mari kita sebut Krylov subspace orde r yang kita hasilkan dalam konteks klasik menggunakan pangkat h
secara langsung sebagai power Krylov subspace kpr.
Sekarang kita menghasilkan ruang serupa menggunakan operator evolusi waktu uniter u yang diberikan oleh eksponensial dari iht.
Kita akan menyebut ini sebagai unitary Krylov space kur.
Power Krylov subspace kpr yang kita gunakan secara klasik tidak bisa dihasilkan secara langsung pada komputer kuantum karena h
bukan merupakan operator uniter. Menggunakan unitary Krylov subspace bisa ditunjukkan memberikan jaminan konvergensi serupa
seperti power Krylov subspace.
Secara khusus, kesalahan ground state konvergen secara efisien selama state awal V memiliki overlap dengan
ground state yang sebenarnya yang tidak berkurang secara eksponensial dan selama ada celah yang cukup antara nilai
eigen. Di sini pangkat u menjadi langkah waktu yang berbeda. Pangkat ke-k dari u adalah melangkah
maju dengan waktu k dikali dt.
Kita bisa memberi label elemen subspace yang dievolusi waktu untuk total waktu kdt sebagai s sub k. Kita bisa memproyeksikan
Hamiltonian H ke unitary Krylov subspace kur. Dengan kata lain, kita
menghitung setiap elemen matriks dari h dalam basis kur. Kita akan menyebut
matriks yang diproyeksikan ini sebagai H tilde. Elemen matriks dari H tilde diberikan oleh nilai ekspektasi ini yang bisa
diestimasi menggunakan komputer kuantum.
Ingat bahwa H bisa ditulis sebagai jumlah operator Pauli pada qubit yang berbeda dan bahwa tidak semua operator Pauli
bisa diukur secara bersamaan. Kita bisa mengurutkan suku-suku Pauli ke dalam kelompok-kelompok suku yang komutasi dan mengukur semua
sekaligus. Tapi kita mungkin membutuhkan banyak kelompok seperti itu untuk mencakup semua suku. Jadi jumlah kelompok komutasi yang berbeda ke
dalam suku-suku bisa dipartisi ngcp menjadi penting. Kalau kita menggunakan unitary Krylov subspace berdimensi r,
matriks yang dihasilkan akan memiliki dimensi r kali r. Kalau r jauh lebih kecil dari n maka kita telah
membuat kemajuan yang berguna dan biasanya r jauh lebih kecil dari 100 artinya kita bisa mendiagonalisasikan ini dengan mudah pada
komputer klasik. Tapi ingat bahwa s n dan s m umumnya tidak akan ortogonal. Kadang-kadang
mungkin untuk mendiagonalisasikan matriks dalam basis yang tidak ortogonal. Tapi ada alasan numerik dan fisik
untuk terlebih dahulu beralih ke basis yang ortogonal. Oleh karena itu kita menyelesaikan masalah nilai eigen umum menggunakan matriks Gram s.
Elemen mn dari matriks Gram diberikan oleh inner product dari s m pada cn.
Baik elemen H tilde maupun S dihitung menggunakan Hadamard test.
Masalah nilai eigen umum kemudian menjadi ini.
Seperti yang dicatat di atas, dimensi unitary Krylov subspace R secara eksponensial lebih kecil dari dimensi matriks awal
kita N. Jadi masalah nilai ini mudah diselesaikan secara klasik.
Sebagai rekap, kita mulai dengan reference state, kemudian mengevolusinya untuk periode waktu yang berbeda untuk menghasilkan
unitary Krylov subspace. Kita memproyeksikan Hamiltonian kita ke subspace tersebut dan kita juga mengestimasi overlap dari
vektor-vektor subspace. Akhirnya, kita menyelesaikan masalah nilai berdimensi lebih rendah secara klasik. Mari kita bandingkan apa yang
menentukan biaya komputasi dari penggunaan teknik Krylov secara klasik dan secara kuantum mekanis. Kita sudah menguraikan ini
untuk versi klasik dan tidak ada analogi sempurna antara pendekatan klasik dan kuantum untuk semua langkah. Tapi tabel ini mengumpulkan beberapa
skala dari langkah-langkah yang berbeda untuk pertimbangan. Ingat bahwa Hamiltonian umumnya memiliki suku-suku yang tidak bisa diukur secara bersamaan karena mereka
tidak komutasi. Kita mengurutkan suku-suku dalam Hamiltonian ke dalam kelompok-kelompok operator Pauli yang komutasi yang semuanya bisa diukur bersamaan dan kita mungkin memerlukan banyak
kelompok seperti itu untuk memperhitungkan semua suku yang tidak komutasi. Untuk membangun H tilde pada komputer kuantum membutuhkan
pengukuran terpisah untuk setiap kelompok string Pauli yang komutasi dalam Hamiltonian. Dan masing-masing memerlukan banyak shots. Kita harus melakukan ini untuk R
kuadrat elemen matriks yang berbeda yang sesuai dengan R kuadrat kombinasi dari faktor evolusi waktu yang berbeda. Ada
kadang-kadang cara untuk mengurangi ini. Tapi dalam perlakuan kasar ini, waktu yang diperlukan untuk ini berskala kira-kira seperti
jumlah shots dikali jumlah kelompok suku Pauli yang komutasi dikali r pangkat 2.
Elemen-elemen s harus diestimasi yang berskala seperti jumlah shots
per kubik. Kita melihat bahwa quantum Krylov diagonalization mungkin berguna dalam kasus di mana jumlah kelompok Pauli yang komutasi
dalam Hamiltonian relatif kecil.
Ketergantungan skala ini menyarankan beberapa aplikasi di mana metode Krylov bisa berguna dan yang lain di mana kemungkinan
tidak akan. Beberapa Hamiltonian memiliki kompleksitas tinggi ketika dipetakan ke qubit yang melibatkan banyak polystring yang tidak komutasi
yang tidak mudah dipartisi ke dalam beberapa kelompok yang komutasi.
Ini seringkali berlaku untuk masalah kimia kuantum. Misalnya, kompleksitas ini menghadirkan dua tantangan utama untuk
komputer kuantum jangka pendek. Pertama, estimasi setiap elemen H tilde menjadi mahal secara komputasi karena
jumlah suku yang besar. Kedua, Trotter circuit yang diperlukan menjadi terlalu dalam. Kedua poin ini
akan kurang bermasalah ketika komputer kuantum mencapai toleransi kesalahan, tapi harus dipertimbangkan dalam jangka pendek. Bahkan sistem dengan pemetaan yang lebih sederhana
WEBVTT
dari yang ada dalam kimia kuantum mungkin mengalami hambatan yang sama kalau Hamiltonian memiliki terlalu banyak suku yang tidak komutasi.
Metode Krylov paling berguna di mana Hamiltonian bisa dipartisi ke dalam relatif sedikit kelompok Pauli yang komutasi
dan di mana H mudah diimplementasikan dalam Trotter circuit. Kedua kondisi ini terpenuhi. Misalnya,
untuk banyak model kisi yang diminati dalam fisika, KQD sangat berguna kalau sangat sedikit yang diketahui tentang
ground state. Ini berasal dari jaminan konvergensi inherennya dan penerapannya dalam skenario di mana
metode alternatif tidak bisa dilakukan karena kurangnya pengetahuan tentang ground state.
Meskipun KQD adalah alat yang kuat, aspek-aspek protokol yang memakan waktu, khususnya estimasi setiap
elemen dari Hamiltonian yang diproyeksikan dan overlap dari state Krylov, mewakili peluang untuk perbaikan. Sebuah
pendekatan alternatif melibatkan aproksimasi state Krylov menggunakan Trotter circuit, kemudian mengambil sampel
state yang diaproksimasikan untuk mendapatkan proyeksi ke basis komputasi dan kemudian memproyeksikan h ke subspace
yang direntang oleh state basis komputasi ini.
Dalam kasus di mana ini berlaku, metodologi yang dikenal sebagai sampling based Krylov quantum diagonalization SKQD
berpotensi menawarkan pengurangan yang signifikan dalam persyaratan waktu dan sumber daya dibandingkan KQD tradisional.
Integrasi teknik Krylov subspace dengan metode sampling dalam SKQD mewakili batas yang menarik dalam
algoritma kuantum.